the rixtag chamber in stockholm was
packed full for the momentous vote
an electronic ballot which took less
than 20 seconds to confirm the outcome
stefan lofvin is the first swedish
premier ever to lose a confidence vote
lofen sat impassively on the front row
as his coalition disintegrated before
his eyes
lofton is a former union boss famed for
his negotiating skills
and since an inconclusive election in
2018 lofthand's social democrats have
governed in a minority coalition with
the greens
while still needing the support of
smaller parties to get votes through
parliament
but his government proposals to reform
sweden's strict
rent control system proved to be a red
line for the left party
who warned that they would bring down
the government unless the proposals were
withdrawn
we kept our word said the left party
leader sir laflin now has one week to
decide whether to call a snap election
or resign and give the speaker of
parliament the task of trying to find a
replacement prime minister
was it bored regardless of what happens
now my party and myself
will together with others be available
to shoulder the responsibility of
leading the country
my primary focus has always been is and
will always be to do what is best for
sweden
that's a heavy hint of what many
analysts are suggesting
that with sweden's fragmented political
landscape and opinion polls showing the
centre-left and centre-right blocks
evenly balanced
it's entirely possible that the speaker
will hand the top job back
to stefan lofvin at least until the next
general election
in september next year the pm may be
down but he's not yet
out paul brennan al jazeera